Apart from the voter
Registration at Comelec offices
Today will also be the
Register
To anywhere
Program
Live from Manila there is first news of Jomer as Presto
Jomer
Susan good morning
Here it is
We are now at the comelec arrozero in the city of Manila
And if you can see behind me
There are a lot of those
Residents who lined up early
To register today is the first day of voters
Registration
For the election
Twenty twenty five
It's still dark
There are already people lined up here
In the comelec arrosero in Manila
For the first day of the voter
Election registration
Twenty twenty five
Jenny flotenya was first in line
With her one month old baby
It was said that it was just past four in the morning
When they came here
They said they preferred to go early
To avoid the influx of registrants
While I'm still gone
I can't work yet because I'm still small
Bali,
I will go back to work because I will go back to work
I don't need to
Absent from work
In conjunction with the opening of the voter
Registration
Today will also be the
Register
To anywhere
Program or rap
This goes a long way to making the process easier
Voter registration
Because rap can help you register in malls
School or any privat
At public places
Because of this
It is expected to reach 3,000,000
The new voters
Based on the most recent
Cobalec data
It's over sixty seven point eight million
The registered voter
All over the country
Five in the afternoon
Meanwhile,
susan
Tomorrow is
Comelec office from eight in the morning
Until five in the afternoon
Every Monday until Saturday
Voters will last
Up to september thirty
Twenty twenty four
While the
Registration under rap
Until august
Thirty ones
Twenty twenty four
That's the first thing
Latest from here in Manila
I'm jomer apresto for gma
Integrated news